chaque jour les rues se rapproche un peu
plus de severodonetsk et de l'iscid
chance qu dans le donbass l'offensive
militaire est d'une intensité maximale
selon kiev
pour y échapper certains ukrainiens se
terrent dans les sous sols d'autres ont
fait leurs bagages et tentent de fuir
les bombardements permanent comme ce
couple mais impossible d'avancer plus
l'étau russe se resserre
ce qui m'a poussé à partir
c'est l' angoisse
les obus tombe à chaque seconde
je ne sais pas ce qu'on va faire on ne
peut pas retourner dans notre
appartement et on ne peut pas non plus
sortir d'ici l'aide de ville sont sous
pression depuis des semaines elles sont
indispensables aux russes pour contrôler
le dombass bassin industriel de l'est du
pays déjà en partie occupé par des
séparatistes pro-russes une progression
qui inquiète volodymyr zelensky
l'offensive actuelle des occupants dans
le donbass pourrait rendre la région
inhabitée ils veulent tous réduire en
cendres
tout cela y compris la déportation de
notre peuple et les meurtres massifs de
sites indiquent une politique claire de
génocide mené par la russie plus au nord
de l'ukraine retour à la terreur sur
karkhiv
des nouveau déluge de bombardements se
sont abattues sur cette ville la
deuxième du cren des attaques qui ont
tué neuf personnes
je vous invite à rester dans des
endroits sûrs dans les sous sols les
abris et les stations de métro
il y a quelques semaines les forces
russes avaient cessé l'offensive pour se
concentrer plus à l'est karkhiv avait
entamé un retour à une vie relativement
normale le métro à vous même rouvert fin
de semaine
la ville doit désormais se préparer un
possible nouvel assaut russe